[Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  there yes we found him  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  hi I'm Bo Chad another lead game  designer on the next Rainbow six game  it's called Tom Clancy's Rainbow Six  quarantine I'm part of a new team in  Ubisoft Montreal that set out on an  exciting new mission create a radically  redesign co-op experience built on the  foundations of one of the best shooters  of this generation what siege is to the  PvP shooter genre we will be to PvE  co-op warranty will test your tactical  skills and survival instincts holding  you and your operators on the razor's  edge it pulls you together as a squad  facing off against an unknown and  devastating parasite you will risk  everything every time you step into  quarantine stay tuned and start prepping  for your next deployment I can't wait to  show you more and have a great eatery  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]